we're going to talk about fighting now
okay because the the there's there's so
many important questions and there's
so many little things i'm curious about
let's start with your
your characteristic your trademark
entrance of the to the eye you enter the
octagon crawling
okay and then the fight starts and
you're
on all fours essentially crawling when
the fight begins
yeah yeah and and what is that about my
first
crawl not up into the cage but crawl
towards
an opponent once the fight started and
that was with rampage jackson and the
ranch-based jackson fight normally you
see two fighters they're always standing
up
and uh and you know john mccarthy are
you ready are you ready
yeah let's get it on right and uh
and uh both guys come you know skipping
into each other
you know i feel like i was i was the
first fighter to ever
crawl towards an opponent while the
fight while the time's ticking right
and then we see connor doing that too
now everyone's starting to do that yeah
it just feels right
everybody's telling me bro listen you
get down sometime
when you look at the next guy that cuts
you off in line or something you just
get down and
you start to you start crawling up to
them
it's intimidating dude if we can just
get my ear cauliflowered i won't have to
do that you don't know
what that is yeah that's why i want
cauliflower because you know
you want to [ __ ] with me film that ear
so with rampage jackson
i kept having these nightmares that that
i would get knocked out
and no matter how the fight
played out i would always get knocked
out and it was always within the first
uh 30 seconds of the fight so you know
one scenario i run out
he'd run at me swing a huge overhand
right the other he would throw a right
uppercut and then another dream it was a
left hook
and i couldn't avoid this inevitable
knockout that i was going to
experience in the first round and you
know i'm a big
fan of sports psychology so i call i
call the
those red zone thoughts and i actually
learned that from rashad evans you know
when you have a negative thought
immediately cancel it with a positive
thought you know instead of thinking of
somebody
beating your ass you think of yourself
exhausted
you're winning fights almost over just
think something positive
and i just couldn't avoid these images
and actual nightmares of rampage jackson
knocking me out so
on fight night i felt like i was going
to get knocked out and i felt like
this was coming for me i felt like
energetically like
i was getting these signals from a
higher power that like
john this is gonna happen to you tonight
and i couldn't avoid it so i i just had
this
super deep prayer
where i got down on my knees and i and i
touched my body from my head
to my toe uh for the first time and i
prayed this prayer
asking god to just give me the super
natural
like reaction abilities um
speed flexibility awareness
and and as i was as as i was
praying this prayer and touching my
myself and rubbing myself
and and meaning every ounce of this
thinking my life is on the line
um i noticed looking at myself that i
was covered in feathers
i was covered in white like a
hallucination it wasn't a hallucination
man it was
it was it was it was real as [ __ ] to you
it was very real to me
it was very real to me i could see
myself covered in like there was like
small feathers in between my fingers and
i was covered in feathers and they came
up
like to my neck and my face was still
like normal not inc fabulous but my
hands and feet recover
and um i felt like i was like this
fighting thing that wasn't
earthly almost and i like
felt this surge of energy power
or flexibility mental acuity and
awareness and sharpness that i had never
experienced
before and i like jumped off my my knees
and like
landed in both feet immediately and i
was just like whoa
whoa but i was just wendy's like
my coaches looking at me like like they
could feel like okay
he is pumped up and uh
coach mingle john's like let's hit let's
hit and immediately i i kicked the pad
and it was like
boom and it like it like it was like
whoa and like
my kicks were lightning fast and i
didn't need to stretch anymore i didn't
need to warm up my lungs anymore
my kicks were going up high i was
jumping higher i was kicking faster and
higher
it was an unbelievable experience and i
actually was able to hang on to this
feeling
and this illusion of myself being in
this alter ego
all the way through the cave all the way
through my walk to the cage
and um and i felt like in that rampage
jackson fight um
i walked into that fight as this feather
man for the first time
and my my idea to
crawl towards him was the only thing
that
had it happen in all my nightmares right
because in every fight i started in my
feet
so something just said get on your knees
and crawl up to him
um and then automatically the the dream
voids itself of him knocking you out
immediately
right so i did that and i got to
kind of i don't know fight in a fight in
an alter ego kind of state and
it was super powerful now to this day i
i say that same kind of prayer over
myself and i believe that
that i transform into something i love
that
i got a million things like that you
know uh when you were in that fight
was time slowed down for you where you
were kind of like things were timed
things weren't slowed down
um but you you you get to this belief
place that you are
that you are uh more than human at the
moment and then you believe that things
as far as just on every realm
are not designed to go against you at
this moment this
is you're actually living in your actual
purpose at this moment this was
exactly what you're designed and born to
be doing this is
this is your mark and uh and at this
moment
i'm being used by my higher power to
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up pretty much yeah dude get
ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off